good morning Hank it's Sunday I've had a
little bit of a surreal weekend first I
did an event where Peter of Peter Paul
and Mary opened for me then I found out
that Ashton Kutcher was following me on
Twitter and then I saw my friend Mary
Fran get married inside an elephant so
ok in order to process all the Surrey
ality we have to split it up into three
parts first Ashton Kutcher
so Ashton Kutcher and CNN were in a race
to be the first Twitter account with 1
million followers and Ashton promised
that if he won he would buy $100,000
worth of bed nets to help prevent
malaria and then he did win and he did
give $100,000 by bed nets and then I
said to the nerdfighters who follow me
on Twitter as a joke that if they got
Ashton Kutcher to follow me I would give
$1,000 to malaria I mean actually not to
malaria like oh hey malaria you are a
terrible disease you are the scourge of
our species here's $1,000 yeah no I
promised I'd give $1,000 against malaria
which I figured was a safe bet because
Ashton Kutcher doesn't want to follow me
on Twitter but once again I
underestimated the power of
nerdfighteria and indeed Ashton Kutcher
is following me on Twitter so I gave
$1,000 to buy bed nets
the second thing folk legend Peter Jaros
opening for me at the Philadelphia Book
Festival also true well actually he
wasn't really opening for me I mean if
he was opening for me that means that I
was opening for a children's band called
trout fishing in America sadly I don't
have any moving picture evidence of this
Hank because I forgot to bring my video
camera to Philadelphia but I did have
the high-resolution pictograph machine
known as my phone so here you can see an
excellent photograph of Peter of Peter
Paul and Mary singing Puff the Magic
Dragon my god Hank the quality it
reminds me of a vlogbrothers video in
March of 2007 and then straight from the
Philadelphia Book Festival I drove to
Atlantic City New Jersey where my friend
Mary Fran really got married inside of
an elephant nerdfighters if you are
considering having a wedding let me give
you two small pieces of advice first
make sure you designate a specific
wedding guest to bring you stuff you
need throughout the evening Hank as you
know don't remember the Yeti NIH's
wedding was a magical day of awesome in
which she and I both almost died of
dehydration because people kept stopping
us to congratulate us while we were
desperately trying to get water and then
my second piece of advice would be that
if it is at all possible get married
inside of an elephant so yeah
nerdfighters if you want
can I come to your wedding put it in an
elephant hey you might have noticed that
this Sunday video doesn't contain a lot
of what would technically be called news
but that's because I'm going to do two
special evil baby orphanage related news
videos this weekend also you might have
noticed that I never ate the 317 peeps
that I promised to eat that's because
after a series of visits to the doctor
it turns out that I can't eat even one
peep without further testing but
nerdfighters I want to make it up to you
by doing 317 of something so leave me
suggestions and comments for things that
I could do 317 times in a single day
that would make you laugh pink as these
homemade argyle socks and nerdfighter
made me remind us don't forget to be
awesome